hey what's up everyone this isn't so
much a tutorial but this is actually
just an answer to a couple of questions
about the media center remote now I've
done a few a question/answer videos
about the HP Pavilion media center
remote and I'll show you guys more about
it in a second so people are wondering
exactly what size is this remote so I'm
just going to show you guys its size
relative to a couple of other things I
have lying around and last I'll show you
that it fits in the PCI Express 54 slot
in the side of the laptop so here it is
next to another phone I have the LG
Voyager um yeah I don't have a tripod
right now but there we go that is the
about the size difference if you know
the size of the LG Voyager there's a
good comparison for you it is not that
thick by the way okay so it's very very
thin and you see here it fits in the PCI
Express slot that's what it says so here
it is I have an iPod Nano on earlier
generation in a case I'm actually I'm
going to take the case off for you it is
broken but you still get a good sized
sized look here so in terms of thickness
they are actually quite comparable very
comparable in size and there it is face
on with the same size so it's kind of
close to the size of this iPod Nano if
you do have this generation but it again
you want to see the size of it here is a
butterfly paper clip which is a lot
smaller than a normal than what else I
was comparing it with but there we go
that's about the same yes we you know
you get the size so there it is this
that's basically a little a few
comparisons with other hardware I have
around and I'm going to show you in a
second how it all fits in the PCI
Express slot on my laptop
there's my laptop right here sorry I'm
it's so big I have to zoom out but in
order to fit it into the side which is
the PCI slot right in the side of the
laptop here there's a little filler you
just pop out the filler which is this
and you can actually just take the
remote and slide it slide it right in
there and it fits perfectly okay it does
it is built for that so it does have
that exact that exact size of form
factor but again you see that thick
it's not a very thick thing so there you
go that's just a little size comparison
you guys were asking for you guys are
messing messaging me about it so that's
about the size of it compared to a few
other things I have lying around that I
can show you guys the comparison uh so
thanks for watching this video and if
you have any other ideas or requests for
videos for me go ahead and subscribe and
I will try to do those videos the best
that I can
so um yeah I do do hardware things with
this camera I do do software things with
my screen recording device and that is
basically it so thanks for watching this
video and subscribe peace